this has been a 10-year process my
partner ron york's and i got the script
Bob Nelson wrote it it was his first
great screenplay he was a on a comedy
sketch show up in Seattle and when the
show ended he figured he wanted to write
a screenplay this is it it's very
autobiographical and he gave it to a
woman named joy Thompson who was our
executive producer she knew Ron she sent
it down to us and we read it and we
really responded to both the humor and
the you know the very the great
characters and and the emotion of the
script and initially we thought we had
worked with Alexander Payne on an
election and we thought that he might be
a very good executive producer we didn't
think that he would we thought this
script was going to be too small and
intimate for him he had done sideways
and About Schmidt after election and we
didn't think he'd he'd do this but
ultimately he called us back we thought
he'd be an executive producer and he
called us back and he said you know I've
got a good idea for a director how about
me that was the good news the bad news
was he didn't want to do three Road Trip
movies in a row and Alexander's very
first conversation with us he said two
things about the script he wanted to
shoot it in black and white and he
thought that Bruce Dern would make a
great woody and and now Bruce you have
said that this is the best role you've
ever been offered this is true and why
why is this the best role I think I was
in the right place at the right time I
think it was important to me that I got
an opportunity to do a lot of stuff that
I'd never done before in my career
there's been a long time since I've been
in a studio movie it's been a long time
since I've been on the road and gone
down a road like we did with this it can
where I was absolutely shocked at the
reception and especially toward me as
well as a movie
he was fabulous the first day he told me
he asked me if I noticed anything I
hadn't seen before on opening day if you
will and I said yeah everybody seems to
be pulling their oar at 8 o'clock in the
morning I'm not used to seeing that and
he said well hopefully that's because we
have eighty five crew members here in 47
who've worked every day on every movie
I've ever made so right away you know
you have a family you know you're back
he said so yours like to use the phrase
dare to risk you can dare to risk with
us because we have your back and then he
said to me don't show us anything Bruce
let us find it and that was the key to
what I do in the movie I had found a
partner who said to me you don't need to
push you don't need to perform shout to
the camera not just let the camera find
your behavior and that's very similar to
what I did when I began with mr. Kazan
same thing it's the culmination of what
I want to do do I have more to do a lot
more I want to do I have no desire to
direct really or anything but actors a
lot of things I want to do him 77 I got
a lot of game left I think he's still
running oh yeah every day and that's a
whole nother sickness I have but that's
the big challenge of this role for you
the challenge for me was number one the
biggest victory I can ever get from this
movie is getting the part I mean let's
face it people put it on your shoulders
that out no no not put it on my
shoulders chose me he allowed me to play
the role that's where it all began for
me it's a lot of times when I've even
been the star of movies where I was not
choice number one silent running it was
the 17th person they went to so I am not
used to being step forward and say come
be one of the jefes and Obie but what it
was wonderful for was that it was the
fact he gives you tremendous teammates I
mean look at this
tell us when did you step in obviously
you were in About Schmidt so he was
working about Alexander before but I I
think that the women are so different
that I don't know that Alexander thought
of me for K you know I don't know when
but I know he was seeing women in LA and
New York and finally he called my agent
and said he or someone from his office
didn't said they had to see Jew he had
to see June immediately so I was in New
York and couldn't see him so they asked
if I would tape some scenes from it and
I did it scenes did they ask you to tape
or what well anything I wanted to but I
of course chose the cemetery is that now
the signature scene in your career I
think it is I think it is I chose that
and the bus the bus scene when I come in
you know on the bus and it I think he
saw that and finally saw that I could do
it you know that it was within my realm
as an actress and those early scenes of
mine I'm a true nag and you know you see
why he might want to live down the
highway go down the highway and get the
million dollars and I mean and I think
that Bob did that and I think that he
told me I didn't know this it's his
mother in law that it was based this
role is based on Bob's mother-in-law and
I'm sure he saw some good things in her
and I think that's probably why he gave
them to me you know the ability to show
you that I would you know protect them
with my life Thomas Wolfe once said you
can't go home again
you must go home again and when I went
home again it's the same way if I go
ahead and go home now that the reason
you have to go back is because it
reminds you and reeducate you of who
they were who gave you the opportunities
they gave you how they dealt with you
and how you dealt with them and I came
away with two very
from feelings number one is make sure in
your life that if you have people like
this in your life you hug them before
it's too late and you tell them exactly
what you feel about him before it's too
late
and that's number one and number two is
the writer Bob Nelson did something for
all of us but for me in this movie I've
never had done before I made a career
out of embroidering my role so that
people might see who I was in a movie
after they got through with the eight
leads cowboy from the left I knew about
it and so in this movie there was no
embroidery at all by me and what Bob
Nelson right and what and and and
actually no performing I didn't feel I
ever was performing and what he does is
in the old house when we go into the
first room I say that's my room June
says this is where David his little
brother died and would he hidden will
says to me you remember that dad now
we've all seen a line like that answered
a hundred times right but nobody writes
on the page I was there right big stuff
I've never been on a movie before where
the actors you know just were so happy
to be there and and you know saw this is
such an opportunity and kind of set the
stage for everybody else
um you know I think it was great roles
for everybody was a big opportunity for
what it's a Forte Forte yeah to do a you
know a dramatic role and everybody out
of the water because he's so still
absolutely he's really the eyes of the
audience and and you know he does a
lovely job with it and and and also Bob
Odenkirk um but everybody was just
really happy for the opportunity and and
it kind of permeated across the board
that's me the most about well just
taking off right on that point was he
sacrificed a familiar way of working for
20 years where he's made a good living
where he's been funny where he's risen
up to the top level of what he does in
order to take risks
and go back and be the linchpin of a
movie and just trust that the father the
the camera would find him if he was a
simple truth if he just was who he was
and for him to do that and in his
mid-forties after a 20-year success was
really amazing to me I admire his
courage and I I mark him outside of Jack
Nicholson is probably the best partner
I've ever had in front of a camera for a
long period of time high praise
well he learned to look and listen and
respond from what he saw in front of he
never I never caught him acting in the
movie a lot of audiences we've had they
don't know if it's right to laugh at the
very beginning like when I poked pointer
something like that or the first scene
where you know about trusting the male
with a million dollars I've seen
audiences particularly in can they were
just like upright in their seats and all
of a sudden 10 minutes later they're
into it and our biggest excitement both
the June and Alberto Thalia the
immediacy of the reaction in Ken was
unbelievable I mean they kind of
exploded as soon as the movie ended and
they were watching it with subtitles so
we all knew kind of that well they get
it here imagine what they might do and
we have yet to show in Omaha
just imagine coming up